we live in a very complex environment
complexity and dynamism and patterns of
evidence from satellite photographs of
videos you can even see it outside your
window it's endlessly complex but
somehow familiar but the patterns kind
of repeat but they never repeat exactly
it's a huge challenge to understand the
patterns that you see are there or all
of the different scales but you can't
shop it into one little bit and say oh
well let me just make a smaller climate
I can't use the normal products of
reductionism to get a smaller and
smaller thing that I can study in a
laboratory and say oh that's something I
now understand it's the whole or it's
nothing the different scales that give
you these kinds of patterns range over
an enormous range of magnitudes roughly
14 orders of magnitude from the small
microscopic particles that seed clouds
to the size of the planet itself from 10
to the minus 6 to 10 to the 8 14 orders
of spatial magnitude in time from
milliseconds to millennia again around
14 orders of magnitude what does that
mean okay well if you think about how
you can calculate these things you can
take what you can see okay I'm going to
chop it up into lots of middle boxes and
that's the result physics right and if I
think about a weather model that spans
about five orders of magnitude from the
planet to a few kilometres and the time
scale from a few minutes to 10 days
maybe a month we're interested in more
than that we're interested in the
climate that's years that's millennia
and we need to go to even smaller scales
the stuff that we can't resolve the
subscale processes we need to
approximate in some way that is a huge
challenge climate models in the 1990s
took an even smaller chunk of that only
about three orders of magnitude current
models in the 2010s kind of what we're
working with now four orders of
magnitude we have fourteen to go and
we're increasing our capability of
simulating those at about one extra
order of magnitude every decade one
extra order of magnitude in space is
10,000 times more calculations and we
keep adding more things more questions
to these different models so what does a
climate model look like this is an old
climate model admittedly a punch card a
single line of Fortran code we no longer
use punch cards we do still use Fortran
newfangled ideas like C really haven't
haven't had a big impact on the climate
modeling community but how do we go
about doing it how do we go from that
complexity that you saw to a line of
code we do it one piece at a time this
is a picture of sea ice taken flying
over the Arctic we can look at all of
the different equations that go into
making the ice grow or melt or change
shape we can look at the fluxes we can
look at the rate at which snow turns to
ice and we can code that we can
encapsulate that in code these models
are around a million lines of code at
this point and growing by tens of
thousands of lines of code every year so
you can look at that piece but you can
look at the other pieces too
what happens when you have clouds what
happens when clouds form when they
dissipate when they rain out that's
another piece what happens when we have
radiation coming from the Sun going
through the atmosphere being absorbed
and reflected we can code each of those
very small pieces as well there are
other pieces the winds changing the
ocean currents we can talk about the
role of vegetation in transporting water
from the soils back into the atmosphere
and each of these different elements we
can encapsulate and put into a system
each of those pieces ends up adding to
the whole and you get something like
this you get a beautiful representation
of what's going on in the climate system
where each and every one of those
emergent patterns that you can see the
swirls in the southern ocean the
tropical cyclone in the Gulf of Mexico
and there's two more that are going to
pop up in the Pacific at any point now
those rivers of atmospheric water all of
those are emergent properties that come
from the interactions of all of those
small-scale processes I mentioned
there's no code that says do a wiggle in
the southern ocean there's no code that
says have to tropical cyclones that spin
around each other all of those things
are emergent properties this is all very
good this is all great but what we
really want to know is what happens to
these emergent properties when we kick
this system when something changes what
happens to those properties and there's
lots of different ways to kick the
system there are wobbles in the Earth's
orbit over hundreds of thousands of
years that change the climate there are
changes in the solar cycles every 11
years and longer that changed the
climate big volcanoes go off and change
the climate changes in biomass burning
in smoke in aerosol particles all of
those things change the climate the
ozone hole changed the climate
deforestation changes the climate by
changing the surface properties and how
water is evaporated and moved around in
the system contrails
changed the climate by creating clouds
where there were none before
and of course greenhouse gases changed
the system each of these different kicks
provides us with a target to evaluate
whether we understand something about
this system so we can go to look at what
model skill is now I use the word skill
advisedly models are not right or wrong
they're always wrong they're always
approximations the question you have to
ask is whether a
tells you more information than you
would have had otherwise if it does it's
skillful this is the impact of the ozone
hole on sea-level pressure so low
pressure high pressures around the
Southern Oceans around Antarctica
this is observed data this is modeled
data there's a good match because we
understand the physics that controls the
temperatures in the stratosphere and
what that does to the winds around the
Southern Oceans we can look at other
examples the eruption of Mount Pinatubo
in 1991 put an enormous amount of
aerosols small particles into the
stratosphere that changed the radiation
balance of the whole planet there was
less energy coming in than there was
before so that called the planets and
those red lines in those green lines
those are the differences between what
we expected and what actually happened
the models are skillful not just in the
global mean but also in the regional
patterns I could go through a dozen more
examples the skill associated with solar
cycles changing the ozone in the
stratosphere skill associated with
orbital changes over 6,000 years we can
look at that too and the models are
skillful the models are skillful in
response to the ice sheets 20,000 years
ago the models are skillful when it
comes to the 20th century trends over
the decades morals are successful
modeling lake outbursts into the north
atlantic 8,000 years ago and we can get
a good match to the data each of these
different targets each of these
different evaluations leads us to add
more scope to these models and leads us
to more and more complex situations that
we can ask more and more interesting
questions like how does dust from the
Sahara that you can see in the orange
interact with tropical cyclones in the
Atlantic how do organic aerosols from
biomass burning which you can see in the
red dots intersect with clouds and
rainfall patterns how do pollution which
you can see in the white wisps
sulfate pollution in Europe how does
that affect the temperatures at the
surface and the sunlight that you get at
the surface we can look at this across
the world we can look at the pollution
from China we can look at the impacts of
storms on sea salt particles in the
atmosphere we can see the combination of
all of these different things happening
all at once and we can ask much more
interesting questions how does air
pollution and climate coexist can we
change things that affect air pollution
and climate at the same time the answer
is yes so this is a history of the 20th
century the first one is the model the
weather is a little bit different to
what actually happened the second one
are the observations and we're going
through the 1930s there's variability
there are things going on but it's all
kind of in the noise as you get towards
the 1970s things are going to start to
change they're going to start to look
more similar and by the time you get to
the 2000s you're already seeing the
patterns of global warming both in the
observations and in the model we know
what happened over the 20th century
right we know that it's got warmer we
know where it's got warmer and if you
ask the models why did that happen and
you say okay well yes basically it's
because of the carbon dioxide we put
into the atmosphere we have a very good
match up until the present day but
there's one key reason why we look at
models and that's because of this phrase
here because if we had observations of
the future we obviously would trust them
more than models right
but unfortunately observations of the
future and not available at this time so
when we go into the future there's a
difference the future is unknown the
future is uncertain and there are
choices here are the choices that we
have we can do some work to mitigate the
emissions of carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere that's the top one we can do
more work to really bring it down so
that by the end of the
it's not much more than that it is now
or we can just leave it to fate and just
continue on with a business as usual
type of attitude the differences between
these choices can't be answered by
looking at models there's a great phrase
that Sherwood Rowland who won the Nobel
Prize for the chemistry that led to a
zone depletion when he was accepting his
Nobel Prize he asked his question what
is the use of having developed a science
well enough to make predictions if in
the end all we're willing to do is stand
around and wait for them to come true
the models are skillful but what we do
with the information from those models
is totally up to you thank you
[Applause]
you